make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing on with our videos on
Doctor Strange here's the thing
I never realized it was gonna do that
well right it was just like dr. strange
or it was like Galactus to me store mama
and then you guys went crazy on that
video which I guess is something
everybody always wanted to see was like
dr. strange meeting Dormammu like what
happens when these two beings of crazy
power encounter one another in this
video they fight and it's the coolest
thing it's amazing I am I am so excited
about this okay there so initially this
pictures up in Mephisto as well right
and for those of you guys who were just
now kind of joining this essentially
Galactus have been banished to the realm
of magic right so like all these magical
worlds and things like that literally
people were panicking and fleeing right
like dr. strange went there to try to
solve the problem but couldn't really
deal with it and then halfway through
all this madness Dormammu hit like
basically bombarded Galactus with
essentially what was like dark magical
energy and kind of transformed him into
what Dormammu considered to be a Herald
and so we ended up finding out Mephisto
had basically a pact with up with
Dormammu insofar as as long as Galactus
was in that realm all those individuals
all those beings who would die would be
symptom a fist around and of course with
all those beings basically being killed
off it could allow Dormammu to to spread
his influence outside his own dimension
and into like the greater magical
dimension as a whole and so what this
does is get a little more nuanced in a
little more into that the funny thing
about this is that with Doctor Strange
trying to rationalize with Dormammu in
saying hey look man you have no idea
what you're doing
the magical barriers are basically being
weakened one of the things that Marvel's
established over the years and they're
they're comics when it comes to magical
energy is there's this kind of invisible
barrier that separates the magical
dimensions from like the regular Marvel
Universe right so I mean it's almost
like closing a door I mean it's what
keeps the dimension of Dormammu the dark
dimension from just like flowing over
into the main universe right it's like a
it's like a kind of invisible gate that
keeps everything separated and
everything locked away what's happening
is that with Galactus his presence in
this universe is essentially opened a
door and by virtue of doing that allows
magical energy to flow into the main
Marvel Universe and then disrupt
everything accordingly so science really
kind of goes out the door and in fact
science and magic are sort of blending
together now we know that happens in
places like Asgard the difference is
that has kind of been mastered and has
been contained here in the main Marvel
Universe none that's happening is just
kind of running amok unchecked with no
one really understanding how to do it
but the cool thing about this is
Dormammu whose argument is I can use
gallant
as a means to essentially walk through
this doorway and enter into the main
Marvel Universe and we know that if he
successfully did that it would be a
catastrophe right because like one of
the things that has been established
over the course of of dr. Strange's
comics in Marvel is that if Dormammu at
full strength were to enter into the
main Marvel Universe pretty much nobody
could stop him because his power is just
so extreme and absolute that it's almost
completely immutable and indestructible
now that's within his own realm the Dark
Dimension even showing up in the main
Marvel Universe it would be extreme but
the funny thing is that Mark Waid kind
of robust that right and will actually
find out why here in a little bit but it
kind of rebuffs that and actually says
it's not really that way when it comes
to Dormammu but the funny thing about
this is that with everything happening
the way that it is the magical barrier
basically flowing into the scientific
barrier it's creating all kinds of
problems and all kinds of chaos and
that's the funny thing is because
Dormammu is by his definition and
exceedingly arrogant guy and so when he
looks at Galactus and he says I've
imbued him with dark energy
he's now majse through all I control him
and then in turn orders Galactus
Galactus blows him off and he's easily
like I'm nobody's Herald now one of the
questions people would ask is why hasn't
Galactus acknowledged Dormammu up to
this point remember when it comes to
Galactus is a being if he doesn't really
consider you someone of significance
he'll just ignore you he just won't pay
any attention to you right I mean you're
an ant and the cosmic scope of things so
you know why would you pay attention to
the going ons of an ant that's how he
functions but it's kind of crazy here
because when door mom who literally
powers up all of his energy and then
goes to attack Galactus Galactus absorbs
all the power of Dormammu into himself
and then absorbs doom Dormammu himself
into Galactus and then goes forward is
like this holy holy powerful entity and
that's the fight it happens that fast
and I know it seems a little
anticlimactic but this is a powerful
statement because what it's saying is
that even in his own realm even in the
Dark Dimension the power of Dormammu is
dwarfed by the power of Galactus and
that's bold that's a bold statement to
make people will look at that and say
that's ridiculous there's no way
Galactus could overpower Dormammu but
that's kind of a silly statement to make
because they've never fought before so
there's no reason to believe that
couldn't be the case Galactus is right
now in possession of all his power
cosmic and all that all the power of
Doremon oh it's crazy like he's he's on
he's on a scale of power that he's never
experienced before and even dr. strange
is like so we're basically screwed like
there's really nothing we can do here
like we're talking about a guy who
already had the power of Galactus right
like the ability to like create life and
all that kind of stuff and now he's got
all those all the magical energy of
Dormammu which amplifies
power even more it's crazy how capable
and how powerful he's become here now
the other half of this is that realizing
what it was Dormammu said in making
reference to Mephisto dr. strange takes
office is fine we have to go find the
fist oh we have to talk him and figure
out what's going on and when the two of
them talk together the discussion of dr.
strange or at least the argument he
makes here is look the the boundary
between magic and science are going away
and is permeating the entirety of the
universe which includes your realm so
it's only a matter of time before your
realm will be subjugated by whatever all
this chaos is that happens to unfold so
either you can be on board or you can't
Harrison everybody else and Mephisto
response is no my realm is fine now of
course the way this is done it's obvious
Mephisto realizes his realm would be in
jeopardy like his dimension would
probably perished but he doesn't side
with dr. strange immediately instead
what he says is I will freak Lia and
Umar the sister of the sister of
Dormammu I will do that but so long as
you make a bargain with me now this is
dangerous because you remember when it
comes to Mephisto he takes the souls of
those he makes bargains with and is
usually a catch of some sort right so
like let's say for example that you are
a person who like lost your legs you
would say if you give me back my legs I
will serve as like your Ghost Rider or
something along those lines
Mephisto would say okay I will give you
your legs back in and you can be my
Ghost Rider and so he'll give you your
legs and then you'll in turn he'll take
away your ability to feel it right so
like you have your legs back but you
still can't use them or he would give
you your legs back and then take away
your arms or something along those lines
there's a catch to it and so basically
there's no real benefit for you to be in
league with him and then when you die he
gets your soul so the Doctor Strange he
basically says okay I will make a pact
with you you can call me for you can
call me up for a favor at some point and
I will be bound to you to fulfill this
this this need that you have this favor
whatever it is you ask of me I will do
it just freak Lia and free Umar and the
reason why is because with Clea being
the ex-wife of dr. strange and Umar
being the sister of Dormammu they're
exceedingly powerful and dr. strange
needs all the powerful allies at his
side that he can possibly get and that's
what he does he sends you know umar and
Clea into the you know really into like
the magical dimensions and says get as
many allies as you possibly can they end
up going to visit a visit nightmare they
end up going to visit despair too
insanely powerful beings right like
nightmares power is extremely he's
powered by like all the nightmares of
sentient beings right so his power is
extreme and where previously he ignored
Clea and Umar said I'm not having
anything to do with this when like
Dormammu as powerful as he is was
defeated then nightmares
okay I'm on your side and that's a
testament to how powerful door mom who
is that's one of the things to bear in
mind among those who are familiar with
like the magical side of things your mom
who's terrifying because like his power
is so incredibly vast and so so wild and
so in addition to that you have dr.
strange who actually goes in pleads to
eternity and to to the Living Tribunal
and this is kind of cool because when
when when situations like this happened
the argument of dr. strange is as a
living tribunal you exist to maintain a
cosmic balance eternity like you're
basically the like the representation of
all life in the universe of like the
entire space of the universe makes up
you guys have to aid us and the response
of eternity is no I will continue on no
matter what form the universe takes
magic will permeate in the science and
everything will go into disarray but my
form will still remain there's no reason
for me to act here and the Living
Tribunal judges in agreement and he says
this is just the new cosmic order of
things that magic will blend with
science and then like that'll be it and
like it'll find a new harmony but
there's no imbalance here there's no
reason for me to judge ah therefore we
are both out of this and this is a huge
blow for dr. strange because if either
eternity or even the Living Tribunal
stepped in fight would be over like that
it'd be done it was just a wave of their
hands Galactus goes back to normal to
the way he was before he gets whisked
back into the main Marvel Universe and
the story ends and that's basically it
but the fact that they choose not to act
means that essentially they're like as
far as like the magical nature of things
and even the universe itself they're
screwed like they're basically kind of
on their own and and seemingly there's
no real way for them to overcome this or
at least that appears to be the case
and so what Doctor Strange ends up doing
is actually calling together pretty much
a whole host of the various magical and
demonic entities out there right so you
got Daimon Hellstrom you've got brother
voodoo you've got magic you've got a
Scarlet Witch we don't really talked
about Daimon Hellstrom he's basically
the son of the devil he was actually
kind of a cool character for a little
while my oldest never really knew what
to do with him outside of his first
appearances but basically is all these
various magical beings that are out
there and dr. Strange's response is okay
well I mean we know we're not
necessarily as equipped as we could be
right because I mean despite the power
they have here even with Scarlet Witch
she's not channeling the power of C'thun
she's not like House of M House of M
levels but what you have here is is
where dr. strange like okay so this is
all we have um then that's fine we'll do
the best that we can he basically gets a
response from like everyone you know
where he's kind of like okay our numbers
are not that high but we you know I kind
of wish they could be uh there's
then allow us to help so what we get
here are the Inhumans we get we get
Valkyrie member a lot of this this
actually takes place it takes place
before the war of realms we have Nova we
have like basically all these different
beings like the Silver Surfer gladiator
of the Shiar Imperial Guard
you've got like oh like The Incredible
Hulk you have pretty much all the heavy
hitters in Marvel you've got a lot of
heavy hitters like a lot of powerful
guys here I think even Captain universe
is here and so Doctor Strange is not
gonna kind of heartened by this you know
because it's like okay so like we have a
chance to basically win here like we've
got some very very powerful people
hopefully it'll be enough we stand a
much better chance than we did before so
where the questions asked what do we do
his response is keep a tight formation
keep the faith and above all do not die
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are no
here to come this explain make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace